hello, how are you, andrés gonzález,
with your brief information for today, monday
, october 4, two people are dead
in north las vegas after an alleged case
of murder-suicide, according to
the authorities, this happened last night
near zenten dot parkway and ali before
the north police  las vegas says a
man in his 40s shot his son
then took his own life identities are yet
to be released another
fatal shooting happened yesterday but was
near sahara and on fire
las vegas metropolitan police tell us that
a man died after an altercation
over the rent with his mother
detectives said a third
person got into the argument and
started shooting police are still on the
suspect's leads if you have any further
information about this incident feel free
to contact the
local authorities or those with a stop to crime to
remain anonymous
the lionel vi detection and vaccination center
that offers over
-the-counter service has  ta now with another site
this will be in the parking lot
above partners field this would be east
for ice road across from the thomas & mack
center hours of operation
remain the same sunday
thru thursday 5:30 to 10:30  tonight
now we turn to the weather forecast
we will see some clouds during
the day with maximum temperatures
around 80 degrees the temperatures will drop
to 70 for the night
there will be a slight chance of rain
for tomorrow in which we will continue with a
cloudy sky that they have  a nice day
los salud andrés gonzález this was his
brief informative the news now in
spanish
[Music]